by the way last night jeopardy the
greatest of all time episode this was a
clue in 1998 football fans debated who
was the NCAA's best quarterback Peyton
Manning or this Washington State
University cougar their pro careers went
opposite ways ok cool that you were a
clue on Jeopardy it's kind of a
backhanded compliment um I don't know if
it was backhanded it felt like it was
yeah yeah I got a lot of message also my
phone starts blowing up just you were
just an answer on Jeopardy I was like ok
yeah kind of surreal I've been a janitor
on The Simpsons and I've been now on
Jeopardy so I think I've gradually
making it into the pop-culture wait I
didn't know you were on The Simpsons
yeah they did a commercial it was just
you know of course it was a
straightforward slap in the face I was
doing a commercial in my Jersey selling
mops yes
so did you voice life's gone full circle
now I did not bother if they asked you
to voice it would you voice The Simpsons
of course ok
are you kidding me when did you embrace
this right that's the difference
probably when I probably when I got out
of prison right just it doesn't cost you
anything to be self-deprecating it
doesn't cost you anything to to not take
yourself so seriously and that's what
that was my problem for a long time I
just took myself so seriously because I
thought I was the end-all be-all and
what you were saying was stupid and I'm
smart well I go back to that one clip
where you're in the locker room with the
Chargers and the reporters asking you a
question and you just go off well he
wasn't asking me a question he actually
kind of baited me and ok the camera
didn't get get the whole thing I kind of
moved him into that chair politely with
my body and then the cameraman spun
around from the other side of the locker
room because he was doing an interview
and caught the the infamous me yelling
at the reporter yeah that was it I just
thought I was more important than
everybody else if I would have told you
and I think its five-year anniversary in
December it wasn't essentially
okay because I remember you know at the
time how can we help you because I truly
and Pauli was really instrumental in
wanting to stay in touch with you
because for some reason we felt there
was something you were vulnerable the
question is would you understand your
vulnerability yeah and then what would
that lead to if I would have told you
that day you walked out of prison in
five years you're gonna work at ESPN as
an analyst what would you say I've said
that over and over I was like I think
you were crazy right I work for the
Disney Corporation and when I walked out
when you and I first time you guys you
guys saw me again was in San Francisco
at the Super Bowl yeah yeah in that
moment if you're like look where we are
right now and and where we are at this
moment and you know I got up this
morning and I went and did a hit on
Sports Center and then I drove down the
road here to see all my friends who've
been a really instrumental in rebuilding
my life because of your support and it's
I mean I just live in a ton of gratitude
and if I can express that at all times
by not taking myself very seriously
either I think that's important yeah
learning to laugh at yourself and in it
and it's hard because people did poke
fun at you and they continue to do so
that's fine because it's not important
it's well you're always the poster child
for you and JaMarcus Russell right for
quarterman there have been a lot of
quarterbacks who have been bust mm-hmm I
don't know why well I think JaMarcus
Russell because mike Mayock or somebody
said it's the greatest pro day sure
thing that he'd ever seen and the money
there's so much guaranteed money yeah I
was drafted alongside arguably the
greatest ever play and we were
neck-and-neck so everybody's like well
look how look at the expectations on the
young man and for me to fail so terribly
I think plays a ton into that so I
understand it I'm not gonna be defined
by it maybe from my NFL career but what
I get to do with my my life move it
forward isn't gonna be defined by some
moment for three years in the NFL
because guess what that's fleeting and
the average length of a career is like
2.8 years in the NFL so there's a lot of
us out there did you ever have a good
Jerry Jones story when you're your
years in Dallas yeah they were you were
a year in Dallas yeah a year and a half
in Dallas and uh to work for him is
special he's as loyal as they come if
you wear that star on your helmet so he
was one of the best owners to to work
for he loaned us his plane one time me
and Clint sterner and Wade Wilson er my
colonel back coach to go up to Montana
to a cabin up there to spend time with
our family he yeah he'd wait wait wait
how does that work I don't and asked him
I go we got to go out there
you didn't say can I use your plane no I
asked if we could use we were gonna rent
one to go up there and I was like maybe
I'll just hit the little man up for this
Hey he let he let McCarthy spend the
night at his house so I'm like you know
let's did you ever go to his house yep
when I first signed there it's beautiful
place and Turtle Creek or at least it
was I don't know I think it's still
there yeah I was gorgeous this this like
round rotunda of a library all wooden
like they're portraits of there are a
lot of pictures paintings of Jerry Jones
in there um I think Merlin Olsen like
there's a Merlin Olsen romper that's a
rønneberg okay there's ya know it's it's
a beautiful house he's a great person to
work for you know I don't know what's
gonna happen there they did it's
interesting to me what I want to know
what their identity is because Mike
McCarthy comes in he's a guy who likes
to throw the ball yes are they going to
be a pass first or run first if you were
advising Mike McCarthy this is the style
of offense I'd run in Dallas what would
you say well I think with Mike McCarthy
looked at his greatest years in Green
Bay is when they were really balanced
with Aaron Rodgers and they were able to
run the football and I think
particularly the year they won the Super
Bowl they did both of those really well
so I think he's really you know
salivating at the idea of Ezekiel
Elliott running the football c50 running
in passing or is it 60/40 passing
probably more like in the 60/40 55/45
realm I think it's gonna be rather even
and it needs to be because you got the
best guy in the NFL of doing it you feed
that horse you know let him do what he
needs to do and let dak be good at the
play-action and getting the ball down
the field yeah
that's what I was and you need
sustainable drives you keep the the year
that they were 13 and 3 they kept the
defense off the field yeah so when the
defense came on the field you got the
impression the defense was actually
better than what it really was I was
interested to see what Jerry Jones was
gonna do with McCarthy in terms of the
staff because he's always been a guy
that's hired a head coach and then
really put a staff together himself
rather than having the head coach put
that staff together do you want your
head coach calling plays I'm if you know
my head coach in college called plays I
just I look at Shaun McVeigh Andy Reid
Kyle Shanahan I don't know if they're
great clock management guy cuz they're
so invested in what they're doing
exactly and and I if I have an offensive
coordinator I want him to do his job I
can be an advisor I just don't want to
have my head coach calling plays well
they it looks like they're gonna hold on
to Kellen Moore which he had a job offer
up at the University of Washington where
Chris Peterson his old college coach is
a mentor and and just left the job there
so I really thought that the answer to
what his ambitions would be is if he
were willing to stay there no one he
probably wasn't gonna get to call place
Kevin Moore may have a lot more
influence in this process and he's
really good at time management maybe he
is more game management side of things
and is able to talk to coach McCarthy
when this is when this is playing out
what do you make it Tom Brady's
Instagram
well what is he saying well I think he's
what I'd really love about Tom Brady is
he the best that's ever played the game
and yet he still has enough
self-awareness and perspective to put
out a message like that where he says
we've worked our tails off you you find
who you are and failure who's the
message meant for I think it's really
meant for the people in that building
but don't they know that I thought it
was strategic that he's saying to the
fanbase
thank you for 20 years I want to come
back but it's not up to me basically and
this is a message to Bill Belichick and
Robert Kraft I think it's a known I
think you've heard Robert Kraft talk he
said he wants him back
Brady clearly wants to be back I can't I
don't think Bella check wants him back
well
that that story played out through the
Garoppolo situation years ago
Bella checks pragmatic enough person
where he would go hey I know where we're
at right now the question is would you
have given up let's say the two Super
Bowls what was it Atlanta and the LA
Super Bowl know if you were to have
Garoppolo nice decision yeah I would
still have made that decision because I
don't think Rob Lowe wins those Super
Bowls maybe he gets one maybe I've yet
to see him in a big situation now the
question is what they do in the draft
would you take Andy Dalton in New
England if you're Bill Belichick would
you take Andy Dalton now over Tom Brady
no I wouldn't take anybody over Tom
Brady no one I'm sorry I've just I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna I don't think they
put the pieces around him this year you
watched a couple of those throws in that
game against the Titans he still can get
it done they just didn't have the pieces
in place he's not the same of course but
I'm not if you put me up against any
quarterback in a situation I'm gonna
take Tom Brady until he says I'm hanging
him up just because of what he's been
but never bet against the patron right
okay but I
I thought Brady was a detriment to the
team this year I looked back and looked
at some throws late in that game and see
if he was late and I I tell you what
Tennessee played some really good
defense they did and he could have been
maybe a split second faster on some of
his throws getting the ball out of his
hand but I mean think about this if
Edelman doesn't drop that ball and you
know you know it's a we're talking about
something different now the game is this
close yeah they're about these types of
things in those football games and if he
feels like he can come back and do it
I'd love to see him as a patriot I can't
I can't imagine him in another uniform I
just I can't and it may very well likely
happen though but if I said he could go
to the Colts he could go to Tennessee he
could go to the Chargers if you could
place him somewhere other than New
England save your answer will come back
with Ryan Leaf right after this and the
Dan Patrick show Ryan Leaf now working
for the mothership as an analyst there
and the number two overall pick in the
1998 draft all right so before the
commercial break I asked you the
question if you could place Tom Brady
and I gave you Tennessee chargers
Colts in order which ones would you do
where would you start ah probably Frank
Reich probably Frank Reich situation I
will say this there's something to be
said for the fact that Tom Brady's been
in the same offense for I don't know how
long he went from McDaniels to O'Brien
back to McDaniel it's he knows it like
the back of his hand he'd have to go
learn a new often sand I can't tell you
I don't care how smart you are how great
you are at it if sometimes it's about
where you're at peyton manning may be
the only one that i can associate where
he went to a different ball club and
excelled but he brought his offense with
him pretty much and adam gase kind of
you know fiddled with it with him and
they made it into what it was but also
the the Super Bowl that year he was
almost a detriment the defense won that
game oh yeah for them so it will be
interesting I just say you would do
Colts for Brady's Chargers Tennessee
because I think Tennessee likes what
they found in Ryan Tannehill in a small
sample size I wouldn't be surprised that
they signed him to an extension
I mean they've kind of been in that gray
area at quarterback like good enough but
you know not great enough what they do
this weekend and you know up against
Baltimore will be really really
interesting but do you see more
quarterbacks coming out I know we're
looking at these quarterbacks now yeah
you can't really replicate Lamar Jackson
no but this is a copycat league you
can't replicate Patrick moams you have a
better chance replicating Patrick
mahomes than you do Lamar Jackson so
what is the future at that position or
offenses in the NFL when it comes to
quarterbacks well I think it's that that
model it's it's gonna be dual threat
even Ryan look at the four AFC
quarterbacks right Patrick mahomes can
move and throw on the run Ryan Tannehill
you got you know Lamar Jackson and so
that's that you'd deshaun Watson so
that's the look in the AFC no the NFC
still a little more drop back you know
Rodgers still athletic Russell Wilson
very athletic athletic yeah so I believe
it's going in that direction
he's Garoppolo athletic well I mean one
of the only times you've seen him run is
when he tore his ACL so yeah not about
right so but if you look at Trevor
Lawrence
he's athletic yeah Justin Herbert
athletic yeah
Justin fields I don't know if he's
considered athletic he's really I think
he's really really I'd like Joe Burrell
really athletic yeah so this is where
we're moving to and the collegiate
scheme of what they're doing in offense
it's it's moving to the pro game right
more rpoS more run was on Reed letting
the quarterback do some more things so I
suspect that's the where we're gonna go
at the quarterback position and we have
a few holdout still hanging there like
you talked about Aaron Rodgers is is
athletic you know but you know if he
could stay in the pocket and just zip it
around that's that that's his bread and
butter but if I said Trevor Lawrence is
available this year and Joe burrow well
I'm a Trevor Lawrence fan I drank the
kool-aid of of Clemson long ago so if he
could if he would could be drafted this
year I believe he'd be the first guy
picked just because of his size the
strength he has all the athletic ability
and but is he capable and I know burrow
is a couple years older than him but is
he capable of doing what burrow did this
year I mean he had arguably the greatest
season a quarterback has ever had
yes the efficiency wise he had I just
don't I didn't see progression with
Trevor Lawrence this year I saw
progression I saw early on he was the
face of college football behind trophy
frontrunner frontrunner and and simply
press too hard and he had a great room
of wide receivers and he threw the ball
up a little bit more than he probably
should have okay
luckily for them Travis a TNS on that
team and he took care of everybody for
the first five games but since that
North Carolina game Louisville games
well Trevor Lawrence is 22 touchdowns
zero interceptions right are you picking
Clemson I am picking Clemson outright
all right yeah they win they win against
the spread I mean if you if you're out
there people and you like to you know
venture out legitimate for entertainment
purposes you know run run with Clemson
plus the what is it 65 and it is yeah
five and a half yeah what it is Paulie
five and half yeah all right yeah run
away with that really yeah
Clemson wins outright Clemson wins 48:38
Paul he called my guy on it or is it
your guy my guy
my guys no longer living I got a guy I
met him in prison okay I'll give him a
call for it did you ever place a bet um
I bet on the Falcons Green Bay back in
the day when I was out of the league a
few years in in Vegas and then I bet on
New England over Pittsburgh so you went
into a sports book in bet yeah in Vegas
so you weren't like that guy from the
Cardinals who no went in while he's
still with the Cardinals in place to bet
like why didn't he just go in in his
uniform I don't know I have no idea but
I wasn't playing at the time yeah but do
you guys how will where well this has
been a while though since you played but
how aware of you got were you guys of
the point spreads you know with the game
I wasn't we weren't aware of it I wasn't
personally aware of it I didn't even I
heard that we were either favored or not
that made us either think in our minds
we were underdogs or not okay but you
didn't know like hey we're we're six
point underdogs and we can cover no okay
no never even crossed trying to get you
to eat more trouble you haven't been in
trouble in a long time Ryan alright so
Clemson is going to win outright would
you take a chance on to Tonga bi-lo um
you know Miami that's hard for me
because he he's done everything in
college to make you believe he's gonna
be a great quarterback I just for
whatever reason don't know if his game
translates to the next level and and
there's nothing against the kid I think
he's amazing he throws the ball more
accurately down the field and I think
I've ever seen a quarterback in college
to your point a little bit earlier the
game's changing it's more about getting
outside the pocket doing things
differently and every time he did do
that he got pulled down he got chased
down he got injured and that for me is a
red flag it just is but I believe that
there's gonna be a team if they feel
like he gets a clean bill of health
they'll gonna reach for him and Miami is
a very good place because they got all
the first round draft picks also I
wouldn't I wouldn't step away from the
Los Angeles chargers doing something
with him and letting them sit behind
rivers for a year but it's going to be a
redshirt year he's not
going to play in the NFL next year yeah
and I think that that would be great you
keep Fitzpatrick in Miami if I'm the
Dolphins and you're sold and you get a
clean bill of health the Scout told me
though he will be the most scrutinized
player at the combine he won't work do
any drills won't do anything but they
put you on the board explain that when
you go to the combine I don't know if
you did it but they put you on the white
board right and then they say all right
here's the play or how does it work with
quarterbacks well he's gonna excel at
that right so he's gonna be at the
combine he's gonna do the interviews and
he's gonna excel at that he's gonna do
the schematic stuff up on the white
board with the coordinators and things
like that he's gonna sell it then he's
gonna sell it the things and there's
enough tape out there on him that Scouts
are gonna be able to look at my only the
medical is what they're gonna be Medical
is gonna be the last thing but also I
feel like if you if you feel like it's
gonna change the next level like guys
get faster bigger stronger right the
ability to ship that was the biggest
change for me like I could run away from
the 300-pound defensive lineman in
college and also in the first time I
decide to loop out of the pocket and I
figure I'm gonna get on the outside just
fine and then you got a guy like Warren
Sapp was 320 pounds who runs a 4 or 4
and he pulls you right down and you're
just like whoa what where am I
welcome to the NFL welcome to the NFL it
was a different it was a different deal
it's great to see him glad you're doing
well and your your boy MacGyver yeah
he's he's getting big that fella but
maybe well he's got a lot to live up to
with a name like MacGyver no he lives up
to it I tell you that he's the best
thing I've ever done
yeah got reason to be proud man he's
only two years of age right he's already
6-foot tall right 40 inches three feet
or inches already so it's great to see
him thank you great to see you Ryan Lee
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]